[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo le
meilleur de la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec vous marion becker
bon genre mario major oriane est notre
invité cette semaine et sébastien chenu
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député rassemblement national du nord et
vous êtes porte parole du rassemblement
national merci d'être là merci et au
programme cette semaine la réforme de la
sncf a été définitivement adopté par le
parlement une adoption très large
mercredi à l'assemblée puis jeudi au
sénat l acte la transformation de la
sncf en société anonyme la fin du statut
de cheminot à l'embauché l'ouverture à
la concurrence
elisabeth borne à saluer je cite la co
construction d'une réforme indispensable
après de longs et houleux débats à
l'assemblée a adopté la loi élan cette
loi controversée entend relancer la
construction de logements et l'offre de
logements sociaux la fin d'un marathon
pour cette loi les députés examinent à
présent le projet de loi pour la liberté
de choisir son avenir professionnel et
c'est l'acte 2 de la rénovation du
modèle social lancé par emmanuel macron
le gouvernement entend transformer le
système de formation un professionnel et
ouvrir l'assurance chômage aux
indépendants et aux démissionnaires sous
certaines conditions et au début de
cette semaine avec la réforme
ferroviaire qui a achevé son parcours
parlementaire
[Musique]
commission mixte paritaire lundi vote à
l'assemblée nationale mercredi au sénat
jeudi le parlement a donc définitivement
adopté la réforme ferroviaire mais sans
pour autant faire dérailler la grève les
syndicats appellent à la mobilisation
héloïse grégoire après plus de trois
mois de marathon parlementaire le
dernier acte s'est joué jeudi au sénat
la version est définitive le projet doit
pour un nouveau pacte ferroviaire est
adoptée premier rang mercredi à
l'assemblée nationale le texte est voté
à une large majorité
l'assemblée nationale a adopté le projet
de loi pour l'avenir du secteur
ferroviaire
et jeudi c'est au tour du sénat pour
l'adoption 245 contre 82
le sénat a donc adopté les conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire et le
pacte ferroviaire un compromis a été
trouvé sur le texte lundi dernier à
l'issue d'une commission mixte paritaire
les principaux points ancré dans la
réforme sont l'ouverture à la
concurrence privée
la transformation de la sncf en société
anonyme et la fin du statut des
cheminots pour les nouveaux embauchés et
cela à partir du 1er janvier 2020
cette réforme est un désastre social
pour ce sénateur communiste en trois
jours à l'assemblée nationale en trois
jours au sénat et en une heure
montre en main une commission mixte
paritaire on vient de mettre à bas
80 ans de service public ferroviaire et
de cette corne entreprises nationales
que la sncf comme le dit alfred
hitchcock
le crime était presque parfait au même
moment sourire et celle fille pour
isabelle borne entouré du président de
la commission du développement durable
et du rapporteur symbole d'une entente
entre la droite sénatoriale et le
gouvernement la ministre des transports
demande la fin de la grève alors que les
syndicats l'état et la direction de la
sncf se rencontrent vendredi pour
discuter de la future convention
collective
évidemment il s'agit pas de refaire la
réforme à la loi est votée je le redis
je souhaite lancer sur de bons rails si
je peux dire la négociation de la
convention collective donc c'est
effectivement un enjeu important puisque
c'est le cadre social qui va s'appliquer
à tous les salariés de la branche mais
je fais confiance aux partenaires
sociaux pour construire un cadre social
de haut niveau une confiance qui n'est
pas réciproque du côté de
l'intersyndicale qui commence à se
fissurer
ils appellent les cheminots à poursuivre
la grève la prochaine mobilisation aura
lieu le 28 juin
sébastien chenu vous avez voté contre
cette réforme est ce que vous ne
reconnaissez pas que le gouvernement a
réussi à réformer la sncf là où les
autres ont échoué
non d'abord on verra ça dans quelques
temps on verra quelles sont les
conséquences de cette réforme
moi je donne un zéro pointé en matière
de négociation sociale au gouvernement
d'ailleurs il ya encore des agents qui
sont en grève et la grève continue à
paralyser le pays empêché un certain
nombre d'ailleurs de français de se
rendre sur leur lieu de travail
je note que le gouvernement ce qui
concerne les négociations de branche a
dit qu'il participerait en observateur
et non plus en acteur donc en terme de
négociation sociale
ce gouvernement a complètement laissé le
champ libre
d'un côté à des syndicats démonétisé
plus vraiment crédible qui n'avait que
la capacité à bloquer à faire de la
grève et à bloquer et de l'autre côté à
une majorité composite c'est-à-dire
républicain est en marche il simplement
ont dérégulé ce qu'était cet outil
public de transport des français donc on
sera très attentif à ce qui va se passer
dans les années à venir qu'il ya des
points qui
pas encore solutionner quid des petites
lignes
quid de l'investissement sur le réseau
le gouvernement a parlé aussi de gains
de productivité
tout ça ce sont des points
d'interrogation que la loi ne solutionne
pas donc par conséquent besoin d'une
nouvelle loi émission le statut de la
fifa allait rester au statu quo une
société qui s'endettent non mais d'abord
historiquement c'est la dette de l'état
historiquement alain juppé à l'époque
avait caché cette dette de l'état dans
la sncf
donc ce qui explique que tous ses choix
stratégiques qui ont été faits aussi
bien sous alain juppé ou pas madame
bornes elle-même elle était directrice
de la stratégie ont amené à cette
solution dont on ne pouvait pas ne rien
faire
enfin ce sont eux les pyromanes ils ont
allumé le feu et ensuite il y à
l'éteindre d'une façon particulièrement
contestable il fallait qu'on regarde les
choses moi je suis pour qu'on ait un
débat d'ailleurs on avait demandé un
débat au sein de l'assemblée ou du
parlement sur la sncf comme aménageur du
territoire parce que je pense que le
transport public dans notre dans notre
pays c'est un facteur d'aménagement du
territoire et c'est par ce biais là
qu'il fallait qu'on puisse parler des
choses on pouvait parler du statut des
cheminots aucun problème différence
entre les administratifs et les roulants
on pouvait prendre en considération qui
une différence un statut c'est pas un
droit acquis un statut ça correspond à
un certain nombre d'obligations
travailler le dimanche travaillé des
jours fériés travaillés la nuit etc
on pouvait mettre les choses sur la
table il ya aucun problème à partir du
moment on disait la sncf
c'est un service public qui permet
d'aménager le territoire c'est-à-dire de
relier des petites villes les unes aux
autres c'est-à-dire linverse du tout tgv
qui relie les grandes métropoles rfl et
débattre dans un premier temps de cette
loi à d'aménagement du territoire qui
s'adresse parce que ça sert à ça le
transport public le transport privé cet
autre chose le transport public c'est un
facteur de développement économique un
facteur d'aménagement de territoire
moi je suis très attentif vous dire dans
ma circonscription des petites communes
qui de 5000 habitants je pense à la
ligne lourches valenciennes que
va-t-elle devenir quelles sont les
garanties qu'on me donne sur l'avenir de
cette de cette ligne denain valenciennes
quelles sont les garanties qu'on me
donne ce ne sont pas des lignes qui sont
rentables économiquement ce que vous
reconnaissez quand même le travail du
sénat sur ce sujet sur cette question de
l'aménagement du territoire de la
préserver sinon ça n'apporte pas de
garantie
je suis désolé il n'y a pas de garantie
à la
nir on re débattra de ces sujets j'en
suis persuadé parce que ce qui va se
passer c'est qu'on va finir par fermer
des gares et des outils qui ont ouvert
il ya 50 ans est ce que c'est ça le
progrès est ce que c'est ça un
territoire qui se porte mieux mais je le
crois pas alors la mobilisation
syndicale 1 continue les syndicats qui
appellent à faire grève la cgt parle
même d'une grève jusqu'au mois de
juillet ce que pour vous il faut arrêter
cette grève a coûté je crois moi je l'
ai dit dès le début que les syndicats
sont vraiment démonétisé comment
voulez-vous d'un côté appelé pendant les
élections présidentielles à voter pour
macron et ensuite venir contester ces
projets a voté contre marine le pen oui
bon ce qui revient à peu près au même
vous l'avouerez en tous les cas à à
prendre des positions politiques ou
comme l'a fait la cgt avec la france 1
soulisse dernièrement et ensuite être
crédible ils n'ont pas de crédibilité
dans le grand public et c'est je crois
aussi l'une des faiblesses manifestes
dans ce dans tous ces débats que nous
avons pu voir c'est que les syndicats
n'ont jamais pu obtenir l'écoutent du
grand public parce qu'ils sont
démonétisé la grève il y avait d'autres
moyens de pouvoir discourir d'autres
moyens de pouvoir faire avancer ses
idées ses propositions et puis si vous
voulez faire grève sincèrement j'aurais
peut-être été plus intelligent en
bloquant le thalys qui emmène les
députés républicains et socialistes
votaient le paquet ferroviaire à
bruxelles ça ça les aurait vraiment
embêté plutôt que d'embêter les français
c'est pour ça que le lien s'est pas fait
entre les grévistes et le grand public
parce que il ya peu de crédibilité chez
les syndicats ce sera d'ailleurs
j'espère un jour l'occasion d'un vrai
débat sur la représentativité syndicale
et puis les français le point de
rencontre ne s'est pas fait alors
aujourd'hui non plus que cette capacité
à dire qu à faire la grève pour faire la
grève mais je pense que le point de
rencontre a pas eu lieu et c'est dur
parti à l'efficacité des syndicats
eux-mêmes à les autres textes polémiques
la loi logement après de longs et
intenses débats elle a été adoptée à
l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après neuf jours de débats 88 eur les
députés ont voté à la loi élan la fin
d'un marathon pour cette fois sur
l'évolution du logement de l'aménagement
et du numérique
quels en sont les mesures clés le détail
avec félix ul
le texte part d'une volonté il faut
libéraliser le secteur de la
construction
ce texte n'ajoute pas de noms
supplémentaires de contraintes
supplémentaires et que c'était pour nous
un objectif fondamental que le
simplifier cela passe par une
réorganisation d'ampleur du logement
social
les bailleurs sociaux vont être
regroupées s'ils gèrent moins de quinze
mille logements les ventes de logements
sociaux vont être facilitée et la loi
sru qui impose aux maires 25 % de
logements sociaux va être aménagée par
exemple les ventes de ces appartements
étaient comptabilisés dans les logements
sociaux cinq ans après leurs ventes
ce sera 10 ans demain la gauche y voit
une menace
cette loi est la première depuis 18 ans
qui en plusieurs endroits de la loi j'y
reviendrai touche à ce qui était un
totem de la république française un
autre article a été particulièrement
discutés il prévoit le passage de 100 à
10 % de logements accessibles aux
personnes handicapées ou seront ces 10 %
de logements accessibles sera
certainement les logements les moins
agréables et est-ce que et est ce que
les personnes qui veulent acheter un
appartement sont contraints d'aller au
rez-de-chaussée ou dans les logements
qui seront les moins bien exposé les
moins valorisées sur un sujet le
gouvernement à reculer celui de
l'aménagement de la loi littoral devant
l'opposition des députés
les dérogations ont été très peu
nombreuses elle a aussi sébastien
chaigneau vous contestez cette loi pour
quelles raisons le logement c'est une
des problématiques voire la
problématique prioritaire des français
dans notre pays on a
cent cinquante mille sdf au bas mot 4
millions de français mal-logés moi je
suis élue d'une circonscription dans
laquelle je sais ce que le mal logement
veut dire et ce gouvernement ne répond
pas à ses attentes
il n'y a pas de choc de l'offre qui va
s'enclencher après cela on n'est pas sur
les attentes en termes de création de
logements puissent de liberté pour le
secteur pour pouvoir construire ce n'est
pas cette autre chose et ce que dit
jacques mézard est vrai oui il y aura
plus de liberté pour le btp pour les
constructeurs etc
mais si vous voulez ce cette loi elle va
libérer les professionnels du logement
mais elle va exposer ce qui devrait en
bénéficier
c'est à dire qu'en réalité elle va créer
encore plus d'insatisfaction encore plus
d'inégalités territoriales dans l'accès
au logement etc sans donner aucune
garantie
je rappelle que le les offices hlm ont
déjà subi des baisses de subventions les
apl ont été augmentés donc on est dans
une espèce de brouillard en ce qui
concerne la politique du logement en
france alors qu'on sait ce dont on a
besoin
la capacité à construire du logement et
la capacité à ce que des français
puissent devenir propriétaire c'est à
dire agir par exemple sur le prêt à taux
zéro nous dans nos propositions
on souhaitait qu'on puisse agir sur ces
questions de prêt à taux zéro pour
permettre aux français d'accéder à leur
logement
un débat sur la loi sru 1 est venue
s'inviter à l'occasion de l'examen de ce
projet de la loi sru qui impose aux
communes des quotas de logements sociaux
est ce que pour vous cette phase est la
remise en cause de la loi sru et moi je
veux bien qu'on reparle de la loi sru
peut-être qu'elle n'est pas adapté il
faut il faut regarder il n'y a pas de
problème on peut en parler mais là c'est
la capacité à vendre des logements
publics construits avec l'argent des
français des sociétés hlm au privé que
va-t-il se passer
bah moi je vous le dis parce que ça
s'est déjà fait ailleurs en angleterre
en allemagne etc
les loyers vont augmenter et les
populations les plus pauvres et bien
vont être amenées à disparaître de
l'accès de ces logements
parce que évidemment elles n'auront pas
les mêmes capacités assez logique que
lorsque c'était des hlm donc non
seulement les français l'ont payé avec
leurs impôts ont payé des hlm avec leurs
impôts
ça va être vendu au privé qui va chasser
quelques par les populations et il est
il réservé justement la vente de ces
logements aux particuliers d'abord il
fallait réserver la vente de ces
logements aux français moi je souhaite
la priorité nationale en ce qui concerne
l'accès au logement pour nos
compatriotes
là encore il ya quelque chose à faire
rentrer dans la loi et ensuite
évidemment je pense que les gens qui
sont locataires sont les premiers à
pouvoir à devoir bénéficier de la
capacité à acheter leur logement
encore faut-il que les banques puissent
les aider les banques ne jouent pas le
jeu et rien dans la loi sur ça je vous
parlais du prêt à taux zéro ça en fait
partie
il n'y a rien dans la loi sur ça donc en
fait ce cette loi elle libère elle donne
de la liberté au lobby du btp au sens
général du terme et elle va contraindre
davantage les français alors le
gouvernement s'était fixé comme objectif
la vente de 40 mille logements sociaux
par an contre huit mille aujourd'hui et
mercredi lors d'une audition au sénat
julien de normandie a semblé relativiser
cet objectif il a dit que ce n'était pas
dans la loi que ce n'était pas une
obligation à ce que pour vous c'est le
début d'un recul et parce qu'ils savent
que ça ne marche pas parce qu'ils savent
qu'à partir du moment où il donne les
clés des offices hlm a déballé privé à
des bailleurs privés et bien il y a plus
d'obligation tenable ils feront
exactement ce qu'ils voudront ils
mettront qu'ils veulent dans les
logements ils les vendront à qu'ils
veulent au rythme qu'ils veulent donc le
gouvernement qui n'a pas voulu installer
une quelconque obligation de ce côté là
eh bien tu es en train de reculer
évidemment parce qu'il voit que ça
marche pas on va passer à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage de la formation
professionnelle et de l'apprentissage
qui était examinée cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et selon le gouvernement il s'agit de
l'acte 2 de la rénovation du modèle
social porté par muriel pénicaud elle se
veut le volet protection du projet
macron un an après la réforme du code du
travail
l'exécutif promet des droits importants
pour les salariés mais l'opposition
n'est pas convaincue
loris beau et chaud et félix ul première
ambition du texte réformer l'assurance
chômage
en ouvrant les droits à deux catégories
de la population les indépendants
d'abord le gouvernement propose une
indemnisation en cas de faillite à
hauteur de 800 euros par mois pendant
six mois jusqu'à trente mille personnes
seraient concernés pour un coût total de
140 millions d'euros par an
indemnisation chômage également pour les
démissionnaires
ce droit seraient utilisables une fois
tous les cinq ans à condition d'avoir un
projet professionnel solide
la mesure pourrait toucher jusqu'à 30000
personnes et coûterait jusqu'à 345
millions d'euros par an deuxième axe du
texte la formation professionnelle le
gouvernement veut mettre fin à la
complexité du système alors le kun
personnel de formation ne sera plus
libéré en heure comme aujourd'hui mais
en euros à plein temps ou à temps
partiel
chaque salarié verra son compte crédité
de 500 euros par an avec une limite de
cinq mille euros
ce sera 800 euros par an pour les
salariés sans qualification plafonné à
8000 euros
une nouvelle instance pilotera la
formation professionnelle france
compétences géré par les partenaires
sociaux l'état et les régions
troisième grand chantier du gouvernement
attirer plus d'entreprises et de jeunes
vers l'apprentissage
les jeunes pourront prétendre à ce
contrat non plus jusqu'à 25 ans mais
jusqu'à 29 ans sébastien chenu
l'exécutif promet que ce texte va
apporter des droits importants pour les
salariés est ce que c'est votre avis non
malheureusement je crois que le
gouvernement a loupé une belle occasion
il y avait
capacité à ouvrir un grand débat sur
l'apprentissage dans notre pays la
capacité à offrir un peu de souplesse
dans l'apprentissage qui est créateur en
tout cas qui permet d'accéder plus
facilement aux marchés de l'emploi et je
crois qu'on a toute une série de mesures
est mal ficelé on nous a privé de débat
également
moi je rappelle qu'en tant que député du
rassemblement national donc ces gens
chez les non-inscrits
nous n'avons que quelques minutes
quelques heures une heure et demie je
crois de débats pour pouvoir faire
avancer nos propositions
donc le gouvernement a voulu serrer
évidemment ce débat ne pas aller au fond
des choses et puis on a toute une série
de mesures est mal financé ma l'imaginé
mal anticipé je dirais et donc je pense
que les résultats seront pas à la
hauteur alors qu'il ya des choses qui
peuvent être intéressantes dans cette
dans ce projet doit moi je ne jette pas
tout à la poubelle
je trouve si vous voulez que la capacité
qu'a le gouvernement à vouloir regarder
là les faillites ou les démissions des
indépendants c'est intéressant on peut
le regarder la capacité même un recul
est-ce qu'on peut véritablement de
parler d'assurance-chômage universel non
mais bien sûr on sait très bien que sur
ça c'est pas d'ailleurs c'est pas bouclé
et d'ailleurs je crois que le
gouvernement aura beaucoup de mal à s'y
retrouver
mais je reprends sur la formation
professionnelle ou l'apprentissage le
fait de recentrer l'état sur ses
missions c'est intéressant mais à
condition que l'état le fasse vraiment
le fait de reparler avec les branches
c'est intéressant mais à la condition
que les branches soit organisée
réellement elles sont je crois plus de
400 il ya 400 branches d'un pays dont
180 je crois qu'ils sont inefficaces
elle est peut-être commencer par
redéfinir ce qu'était une branche les
obligations qu'elles avaient et c est
sur ce point justement les régions ne
sont pas contentes que les branches
professionnelles justement reprennent
l'apprentissage elles craignent un
risque pour le mariage territoriale des
formations plus ou moins importantes
selon les régions c'est un véritable
risque
non je pense que les régions se trompent
je pense que les tailles dans sa mission
lorsqu'il reprend la main sur
l'apprentissage une gabegie à des
priorités à définir il faut vraiment que
l'état le fasse et puis les régions ce
sont ses bras armés se sont elles qui
gèrent les bassins d'emploi elles sont
en capacité de guider l'état sur les
ouvertures de cfa et c'est bon je pense
que ça ça peut aller dans le bon sens
voyez vous mais par exemple on n'attaque
pas
on a voulu faire une proposition dans ce
sujet quand les régions de disques il y
aura des fermetures de cfa ça vous nous
dites c'est pas vrai il y aura
probablement des fermetures de cfa si
l'état n'est pas en capacité de faire
rencontrer l'offre et la demande saas
est une évidence et c'est pour ça que je
pense que leur leur espèce de deux
machines d'outils publique la france
pardon à s'investir me semble être une
usine à gaz
ce qu'elle aura françois dit alors à
quatre interlocuteurs l'état les régions
à les syndicats de salariés les
syndicats patronaux et je pense que en
réalité c'est une usine à gaz un bon
donc le truc est mal articulés mais je
pense qu'ils ne touchent pas surtout
l'essentiel de ce qui fait
l'apprentissage dont on avait fait une
proposition et moi je la portais qui
était de permettre l'apprentissage pour
les les bénéficiaires du rsa jusqu'à 34
ans révolus il ya une expérimentation
qui se fait en loire atlantique
là je pense qu'on avait des champs qui
permettait d'ouvrir l'apprentissage à
des hommes et à des femmes qui ne sont
pas forcément les plus jeunes mais qui
pourrait en bénéficier et se réinsérer à
travers l'emploi
en tous les cas reprendre pied à travers
l'emploi et à travers l'apprentissage
donc le gouvernement il va pas jusqu'au
bout c'est dommage parce que il y avait
des choses intéressantes il ya des
choses intéressantes dans le texte on va
voir comment ça évolue mais je pense que
la montagne a accouché d'une souris
allez il est temps à présent de
retrouver notre partenaire du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jim géré assez vous nous avez rejoint à
bonjour et bienvenue aux genres yanon
jour sébastien chenu on va parler du cas
de l'aquarius ce bateau de réfugiés qui
au coeur d'une crise diplomatique entre
la france et italie
emmanuel macron et des mots assez durs
vis-à-vis du gouvernement de guiseppe
compte t il a parlé de cynisme le
gouvernement qui avait refusé
d'accueillir le bateau en dehors de
toute considération politique
est-ce qu'ils avaient pas quand même un
principe d'urgence qu'on aurait dû
respecter qui aurait dû prévaloir dans
cette affaire un principe d'urgence
c'est-à-dire d'accueillir oui je crois
que c'est irresponsable que de présenter
les choses ainsi
le principe qui devrait être le nôtre en
tous les cas guider les pays c'est le
choix que font les pays en matière de
politique migratoire dans l'intérêt de
leur population
qu'il y ait des gens moi j'ai de la
compassion pour ces gens là je veux dire
je souhaite que on les sauve quand il ne
périsse pas en mer etc
mais qu'ont les raccompagne de la
louisiane car nous n'avons rien à leur
offrir
et c'est ça la logique qui devrait
présider au choix des étapes c'est s'il
valait si les états veulent accueillir
qu'ils accueillent mais si les états ne
veulent pas qu'on ne les oblige carte
mère face à cette situation si vous
aviez été par exemple chef de l'état
qu'auriez vous fait nous aurions demandé
que des bateaux repartent d'où ils
viennent nous aurions entamé
probablement depuis bien longtemps
des négociations avec d'autres pays
pourquoi la tunisie n'est-elle pas en
capacité alors qu'elle est toute proche
d'accueillir ce bateau nous aurait mené
au également probablement une autre
politique diplomatique qui vise à ne pas
déstabiliser les pays d'origine nous
aurions proposé nous nous avons proposé
nos oreilles ont installé la capacité
est ce que les demandes d'asile se fasse
dans les pays d'origine de façon à ce
que on ne met pas les pays devant le
fait accompli une demande d'asile se
fait dans le pays d'origine
elle est traitée par nos services
consulaires et ensuite si l'asile est
possible les gens peuvent venir s'il
n'est pas possible ce qui est le cas
bien souvent tous les cas de ces gens là
en particulier et bien
le traitement se fait sur le territoire
concerné mais il n'y a pas de
possibilité de mettre les états devant
le fait accompli parce que c'est une
histoire sans fin sur ce nouveau
gouvernement italien dont on a beaucoup
parlé cette semaine c'est un modèle à
suivre pour vous pour le rassemblement
national
dans tous les cas ils tiennent leurs
promesses ils tiennent leurs engagements
et ils font ce pourquoi ils ont été élus
les italiens ont envoyé je crois un
signal très clair à l'union européenne
en leur disant nous ne pouvons plus
accueillir
nous ne pouvons plus nous ne voulons
plus accueillir tous ces migrants qui
viennent 700 mille migrants sont arrivés
sur les côtes italiennes durant toutes
ces années
eh bien ils ont des dirigeants qui leur
disent qu'ils ont entendu ce message qui
leur disent nous n'accueillerons plus de
façon indéfectible
tous ces gens ce gouvernement il s'est
construit sur une coalition entre la
ligue du nord et le mouvement 5 étoiles
c'est justement ce principe de coalition
d'alliance que vous cherchez à atteindre
vous aussi en france c'est une alliance
et plusieurs choses c'est la possibilité
de s'allier avec des mouvements
politiques la possibilité d'attirer soit
des gens qui viennent d'autres
mouvements politiques ou la possibilité
d'attirer soit des gens qui viennent de
la société civile c'est ce qu'a fait
banal macro il s'est allié au modem un
parti politique il a rallié à lui des
gens qui venaient du ps et des
républicains et puis il s'est ouvert à
la société civile
la ouvriers je trouve que c'est
intéressant elle nous on souhaite
pouvoir s'allier avec des mouvements
politiques si eux mêmes le souhaitent
ils sont pas très nombreux aujourd'hui
dans la sur la carte électorale
française mont souhaitent attirer à nous
des gens qui viennent de gauche à droite
et puis des gens de la société c'est ça
que vous appelez désormais rassemblement
national c'est ça est ce que le ce
nouveau nom prend auprès des militants
que vous rencontrez dans votre
circonscription est ce que ça ça
fonctionne
il va falloir l'installer ça fait quinze
jours trois semaines
donc on va prendre le temps de
l'installer et puis les élections
européennes seront je crois un bon
moment et une bonne opportunité pour
installer ce rassemblement des
françaises et des français qui croient
que la nation ça vaut encore quelque
chose que le rôle de l'état
il est important contrairement à ces des
régulateurs que sont les amis des
venelles macro justement sur ce
rassemblement marine le pen plaide elle
pour le rassemblement de tous les
patriotes de tous banques y compris venu
de la gauche
marion maréchal
une stratégie différente puisqu'elle
parle d'union des droites à son sujet
vous avez des démos dans le point il ya
quelques jours vous dites chez elles les
appétits personnels passent parfois
avant les enjeux collectifs qu'est ce
que vous voulez dire que oui enfin il
faut repréciser les choses je parlais de
ses appétits personnels intellectuelle
d'accord voilà
marion maréchal mène un chemin que je
trouve tout à fait louable et courageuse
de créer une entreprise de faire de la
méta politique c'est-à-dire de forme et
d'irriguer les cerveaux de nos idées et
on en a forcément besoin et puis il ya
ceux qui continuent le combat électoral
derrière marine le pen aujourd'hui donc
moi je pense qu'on a besoin des deux
d'ailleurs on gagne d'abord dans les
têtes avant de gagner dans les urnes
mais pour gagner dans les urnes il faut
des gens sur le terrain et marine le pen
et les élus du rassemblement national en
font partie donc on a besoin des deux je
pense qu'il faut pas se limiter à
l'union des droites
c'est un peu restrictif bien sûr tu faut
cueillir les gens de droite moi je viens
de l'ump j'en suis l'exemple il faut
accueillir les gens de droite qui
veulent nous rejoindre mais notre
discours est bien il se destine aussi
aux gens venus de la gauche aux gens
qu'ils ont été trahis pendant de tant
d'années qui sont attachés au rôle de
l'état à la république à ses valeurs à
la capacité que la france et a protégé
les siens oui notre discours il se
destine à tous dernière question
peut-être jean marie le pen a été
hospitalisé cette semaine à 81,10 on dit
très fatigué qu'est ce qui symbolise
encore pour leur assemblée nationale ce
qui symbolise encore quelque chose
ailleurs pour le rassemblement national
je ne sais pas ce qu'il symbolise
puisqu'il n'est pas n'est pas membre de
notre mouvement politique jean-marie le
pen est probablement aujourd'hui à la
stature d'un homme politique qui a
marqué l'histoire politique de notre
pays qui était probablement visionnaire
dans ses analyses
probablement excessif sur d'autres
points
mais il est aujourd'hui en tous les cas
est encore bien vivant quelqu'un qui
marque les français et qui a fait des
années je crois pertinentes à certains
moments de son histoire politique et ce
sera l'eau de la fin merci beaucoup et
sébastien chaigneau merci jim merci
mario et merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
paris